All right. Thank you
very much. All right can I have
your attention please I know
that we have. Five minutes late
for awhile up and make sure
that you respect of everybody's
time- make sure that will lead
you all of to do or by eight
o'clock. Those of first of all
thank you very much for common
and- diss the assembly select
committee on hate crimes.
Public hearing on compassionate
California. An interface
dialogue and the one again
thank you for your interest and
for being here before I proceed
I will like to us or you the
poor president- I got to think
food new Peter the move Peters
unified school district. For
providing so- did their
ballroom for this evening's
event and definitely- thank.
Chris for you for your help
and- before we start I would
like to ask the president to
lead us. For a pledge of
allegiance so please price.
Ready again our pledge. Ally of
the United States of America
and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and
justice for all. Thank you.
Thank you president Norwood
thank you for hosting and thank
you for. This much appreciated.
Thank you a of. Officer
formality I'd like to introduce
myself my name is Kansen Chu
I'm the chair of the assembly
select committee on hate crime
and I'm happy to be the year
here with all of you tonight a
with my colleagues on the
select committee our friend and
colleague for long time since
we were in the south to city
council together. In assembly
member Ofshe Kalra. And also on
the die is a like to- welcome.
Home Fremont vice mayor Raj saw
one. In the staff is to passing
me of some. A business card in
a while the recognize the
Melissa Koffler whose days of
the- legislative aide on the
woman at the. The feel rap for
the assembly member Richard
bloom Kamala all the way from.
Said Santa Monica to join the.
And from a senator Bob what
call skis office we have the
one and only Tim Orozco all
right. And. Also wallet to
recognize our US house a
district four councilmember
land dip. I'm. Come home to the
from them and also of the
introduced- from the city of
Fremont Roch tall long.
Assembly how from congressman
role Connors office hip million
yep thank you very much for
coming. M. from supervisor Dave
Cortese's office we have cabin
the- all right Carol. Then and
also from the Santa Clara
unified school district how of
the board vice chair Jim Canova.
Thank you very much. All. Right
he was dead I also want to
acknowledge a group of
students- from meaty high
school the root of advocacy.
Roger road map the media
because he projects student I
have Matt us to the several of
them and my- committee office
already in Santa Clara. But
they were very interested in
this topic so the teacher has
brought about what twenty of
them here to join. And welcome.
All right worst drought we'll
also how from representative
from care. See a dark here
cùng what's the care sample
cut comma. Council over
American Islamic relations
right as well as a and W. C. P.
not a different bill be here
late but. I'm is that where
the- thank you thank you very
much for coming you know I
Creek this says subcommittee on
hate crimes three years ago in
response to the rice all pay
crime through all the state of
California. In addition to
myself to come meet he is make
up of pan of my colleagues in
the California State Assembly
one of them is here. And the
assembly select committee on
hate crime serve as a tool to
foster community engagement and
open dialogue. And
collaboration of ethnic and
religious organizations LGBT Q.
groups law enforcement number
profit and other organizations.
As much as California has drive
to inclusive. And to
progressive we still have the
highest number of hay group.
The sharp increase in hate and
bullying related crimes even
sold those crimes are generally
under reported. So I aid
requested audit by the state
auditor other hate crying in
California we have do we
receive the result in may of
twenty eighteen include- and
the result from the audit
report of were very
disappointing but not
surprising. Hey crime were on
the rise yet our state auditor
fall many- when. Under reported
I reported so due to a variety
of reasons including the lack
of awareness training and trust
between the community and the
law enforcement. So in order to
protect our community and
captured appropriate date. We
need stronger policies and
implementation of bills
policies across the state. This
year I have authors for bills
god to deal with to protection
from hate crime us should a
trying to implement some of two
recommendation from there a
report. They didn't it did take
up- didn't go too far I didn't
not talk go very far the- AB
thrill one. Of both a hate
crime data collection and all
reach bill. And there will have
mandate the repeal of all law
enforcement agencies. Every
three years to your value a
their accuracy of the hate
crime data an agency Hey crime
policies because they law
changes road road we got. A
rather the regarding to the
hate crime I wanna make sure
that all the- his officers a
get hated. On the most current
a hate crime law. AB fifteen oh
two which is a bill that would
require peace officers to
receive initial and ongoing
training. On how to deal with a
crime. Es de all did I mention
earlier found that under
reporting. Work harder- partly
due to the lack of updated
training so among make short I.
R. peace officer receive
adequate training. To deal with
this is a very important issue.
Unfortunately those bill didn't
really make it into law.
Partially because this state
legislature this year we have a
police involved shooting bail
of what we're trying to. And
that really trying to change
the police officer's own own
use of extreme force or use of
force in general. So that a put
a lot of. Of a burden responses
for. The you post police
officers standard training
which is a organization there
are responsible to provide a of
the materials and the training
for de um of peace office so
they did oppose from pretty
much to say well we're we don't
have enough capacity. The van
was to do to do more of the-
training materials and pro by a
training to our- of peace
officers up and down the
California so their own but I'm
not I haven't given up on those
ideas yet. So next year I would
be- willing to- work with my
colleagues here and continue
push him for about her
reporting more accurate
reporting better training for
the peace officers to address
this the. Escalating problem in
our state. Often so another
another legislative late
another legislative idea which
I really clean cannot claim
credit. Because I know many of
the cities and the counties and
California have adopted this
compassionate other a
resolution. So I wanted to make
California the first state in
the United States. That adopt
this compassionate resolution
which world declared California
V. the pot compassionate to
stay in in the United States of
America. That's my is C. R. one
little eight. Were brought to
vote connect your in the
assembly and is one of the
important reason why we are
here. Today to host those
hearing. Making California- and
compassionate state is not an
idea. And I can claim image
credit I wanted to the thank.
The city of Fremont you know
that we have. The adopt this
I'd this to a- resolution
earlier you know- but as the
Buddhist myself. It will have a
Hindu hater. Compassionate is
to read a way of life. I don't
think we can step out hate with
Dahle compassion. And being
genuine to our approach. This
is a ball treating others was.
Empathy with respect and
putting effort into being hi.
It is such a fortunate thing
that our district is so diverse
I love to brag about this
diverse city anyone anywhere I
go and I think that along with
a great policy ideas. There is
a lot of room for us to be
kinder to each other in order
to prevent and a drop the
hatred that is spreading
rapidly around our nation. And
today we will be hearing from
our panel a distinguished panel
of M. of religious leaders in
our community from a from the
district and how they help
their community to deal with
and to prevent hate crimes Chu
compassion. There by will be in
your hand out along with a copy
of the hate crimes all that
report. You can pick the pick
them up- at the registration
desk outside inside. And we're
we're outside okay great. So
before any introduced AB-
detected distinguished
panelists here. Of a like to
ask to- my colleague here to
make any statement. Thank you
very much chair Kansen Chu I do
wanna. Certainly thank- a Chris
nor would the board I mean the
it would not just be and an
excellent advocate for
education before hosting us- a
this evening as well as a-
upper per- Basel water vice
mayor free one for being here
as well- and- and the students-
the many students I know I
always enjoyed me without the
other students here. And I've
enjoyed also seen them the
student the climate strike as
well and I appreciate the
advocacy overseeing for young
people in the for them to be
here I think is really
important- and the- the
panelists. And I want to get to
the palace in the good thing is
that you have about thirteen
minutes each usually you got to
Sacramento if you have one or
two minutes so I'm glad we have
a chance you actually to finish
some thoughts. As you- as you
present- but we have an all
star panel here that I've known
many of them for many years. I
certainly compassionate and
very thoughtful leaders so I'm
so grateful that you're all
you're not able to represent
this community but as a Kansen
said it's very diverse
community I think it's a very
loving community. But we also
have our challenges are always
important for us to engage and
talk with one another and be
that. Model for the rest of the
state especially as- it is
Kansen moves forward with
passion California resident
Xin. I only talk about
compassionate California that
are being compassionate to be
apart and should be what woven
into everything we do whether
it's budgets- whether it policy
or whether it's community
advocacy and so that's why. I'm
very grateful to Kansen Chu up.
A chair of the select committee.
Thank you thank Kansen Chu so
much. His compassionate
leadership- which will
certainly be missed a state
legislature but it's not going
anywhere because he's not going
anywhere. And I won a. This is
a you know get a Kansen days
were always going to have them
as part of our community
sharing that compassion love it
so I want to thank Kansen and I
look forward to hearing from
our panelists. All right thank
you AJ. And vice mayor. Thank
you. Very well then. Good
evening assembly member is-
honor to be here- I really
appreciate you taking the lead
on this- compassionate.
California which is one. I in
Fremont we are fortunate to
have passed the- compassionate
Fremont charter. And basically
that's relies on the golden
rule which is everybody wants
treated equally. And at that we
take care of our fellow
members. And. And so- it's very
I need to be some of the hate
crimes are happening a lot of
them started for example nine
then- many of our Sikh
Americans suffered a lot of
hate crimes and have because of
the misperceptions. And just
recently in Sunnyvale we also
had a hate crime which was a
Hindu American was targeted
because it up they were of
Muslim. And so on only a lot of
these are fear based- crimes
or- you know tribalism and also
a mental health issues and so-
I definitely believe that the
state needs to have better
reporting- and I appreciate the
assembly member for- I trying
to pass this new- law. Which
will allow for better a
classification of the crimes by
the police department and also
be logged in better in the
department of justice serving
classify the a hate crimes
better than we can actually do
something about that so I
definitely command. Our leaders
assembly member Kansen Chu is
taking the lead on this and of
course our good friend assembly
member ash Kalra thank you for
having me and look forward to
all the speakers it's a great
panel. When I know most of the
panelists those again thank you.
Thank thank you very much I
wrote. Five number for. Us to
the- president. To make some
I'm and I also want to
recognize. That our
superintendent assure Jordan is
in the audience. Wave thank you
very much for letting us use
your a beautiful a room here
and also we have just joined as
a Michael hi another school
board member. For Milpitas
union school district en en
captain- whose- on the West
Valley mission college bloom.
And thank you. President this
feature is yours. Thank you
and- our office- Kansen thank
you very much for being in a
previous unified school
district of known you guys for.
A long time in your work- your
work around the community in
the county has always been very
strong your relationships with
schools and school districts-
have as have been equally as
strong. Because you understand
where the work starts so one of
the reasons why we're grateful
to have the opportunity to host
this type of event because we
deal with- hate crimes in a
very different way. It's where
and in the school system is
called bullying. And so the
fact that this is being hosted
here will be able to share it
with our students with our
teachers. With our leaders and
saying that we have an
opportunity in a role to play
as we create as we work with
the development of our young
people. If we can help reduce
bullying we should believe that
there's a correlating affect
that we should help reduce hate
crimes. So I'm very excited to
be here to listen to this
distinguished group of
panelists. And look for the
evening. Thank you. Thank you
president or what. So let's get
to day Axford less. Introduced
to the panelists. A star from
my- from my laughed you're
right. Is the U. mon tech here
and will. Yes thank you. Give
them a round of applause you
might might will go one at a
time okay will die and be
patient. We'll get to you. Good
evening ladies and gentlemen-
my name is tÁi here on water
I'm here on behalf of the
Muslim community here in the
South Bay- I'd like to begin by
thanking assembly member Chiu
for facilitating this. And of
course the rest of my friends-
right in front and on the panel
as well. I've got thirteen
minutes for an imam thirteen
this is actually very very
little. But and because of the
topic that I've been assigned-
I'm gonna be very theological
if I may and so I'm gonna free
I ask for your forgiveness and
hands for that. But with that
said I'm hoping I don't take
the entire thirty minutes but
don't be surprised if I do- the
question that was asked is in
our religion and our faith how
do we promote inclusivity and
compassion towards others- as a
Muslim- I turn to of course.
The holy text as as Muslims we
turn to the Koran first and
then we turn to the traditions
of the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him and I'm gonna spend
a few minutes. Just speaking
about that- the Koran we
believe has a hundred and
fourteen chapters and except
for one of them- every single
one of them begins with in the
name of god the most
compassionate the most
merciful. So that's the first
verse in the Koran we talk
about compassion and mercy- if
we- look at of course the Koran
is about the size of the Old
Testament which I spent two
years of my life memorizing
from cover to cover. And my son
is done next until the fourth
generation who has memorized it
from cover to cover- but
there's for have topics that
are heavily stressed- in the
Koran compassion. Of
benevolence justice and wisdom.
And all of these have to do
with things that where- dealing
with today in fact there's a
direct versus the Koran were
god says my mercy encompasses
all things we are reminded in
our tradition that mercy being
merciful is intrinsic. As to
who we are as human beings in
fact the Arabic word era
because not my mother tongue
just for the record my parents
are from India I learned Arabic
much later in my life- the word
for wound. In the Arabic
language is awesome- and I'm
actually literally means mercy
and that's where members we
built we believe in our
tradition where mercy begins
the love between the compassion
the love between the mother and
the child which then gets
passed on to. The community
there's two verses in the Koran
that I want to share portions
of the verses that I want to
share in this these are sort
of- Guiding. Light for us in
our tradition- god says in
chapter forty nine let not a
people ready killing other
people perhaps they may be
better than them. Nor let women
ready kill other women perhaps
they may be better than that
and do not insult one another
and do not call each other by
offensive nicknames the Koran
is very very clear about just
calling others by names are
making fun of other
individuals. Let alone hurting
them right one is to make fun
of someone and then the other
is to bully them or a hate
crime and that sort of the
foundation. As far as you know
we've been talking about I've
I've lived in the Silicon
Valley I've lived in San Jose
for- thirty seven years now- we
talk about a very diverse
community how to Muslims deal
with diversity- if you've been
to any. Muslim of you know
there's a verse of the Koran
that is often cited an off
shared we've created you from
male female did you people in
tribes so that you may know one
another. Indeed the most noble
of you the sight of god is the
most righteous of you. And so
we. He our tradition believe in
diversity we believe that
people are going to be diverse.
Act traditionally as Muslims-
when we refer to individuals-
as a sign of remembering that
you're known by the name of the
town that you're from so in
fact one of the- some of the
most. Up with resourceful books
that we have in our tradition
are so for example let me give
you an example one of the
collections of the traditions
of the prophet Muhammad which
is really really famous. Is the
individual's name no one knows
about his name they know ms
Behati. The reason they known
as bodies because he's from the
town of bajada. And similarly.
You know when I was studying-
my I'd no one ever knew my last
name my last name was a many
key. The American. Yeah that's
that's very interesting and so
we when we talk about diversity
diversity is intrinsic to who
we are but we are one family we
are one family as a people of
our faith and we're also one
family as humanity. We turn to
the traditions of the prophet
Muhammad and this is something
which is- you know a very
commonly mentioned in every
every religion has sort of a
saying around this in in our
tradition we remind ourselves.
No one truly believes until
they desire for their brother
or sister with a desire for
themself in other words if you
want peace mercy compassion for
yourself that's what you you if
you're not a perfect human
being unless otherwise you
desire that for the other
individual. And a lot of times
my kids are a little older now
when they understand but when I
was younger- my children sorry
when my children sorry when I
well when I was younger too but
when my children. Were younger
and they wouldn't see me at
home in the evening and some of
you who've known me in the room
no that I was a great advocate
needs senior a lot of different
places. My children ask and say
why and I would really believe
and I tell- individuals that
you know I San Jose is home for
me California is home for me
the United States is home for
me and my religion. Teaches me
too sure that my home my and
remains a safe place and so it
is my faith. That drives me to
go up there not to convert
people very clear about that is
not I'm not do and you know
that you know I'm not here to
proselytize I don't do my work
to proselytize I'm here to do
my work because that's I feel
that it's an obligation on me
as an individual. To ensure
that I do my part for my
community that. You know we
don't hate you and we don't
hate each other and when we
talk about hating each other
you can't you know sometimes
when you don't know someone-
you may hate them but you may
still be a wonder around them
right who. Are they what are
they do it took a I've. I've
lived in San Jose for. Of a
number of years now and I'm for
some of my neighbors it took
them a little while to warm up
to me. I'm gonna be honest with
you this and as a for god's
sake. You know they couldn't
figure out who I was when they
figured out it was Muslim. You
know you it's like okay what do
you do inside your house. Of
until they saw my kids playing
outside and running outside in
me playing ball my kids and so
on and so forth it's sort of. A
humanize me. Around my
neighbors- but I didn't do that
for my neighbors I did that for
my own self I did that because
my faith teaches me to be
compassionate. And to be. Nine
towards the individuals around
be. I just want to share a few
traditions. From the prophet
Mohammed- this is of course
this is fourteen hundred years
ago a man came to the prophet
Muhammad said- profit I have
ten sons and I've never kissed
any of them. The profit looked
at looked at him and said he
who has no compassion will
receive none. Right when you
talk about compassion this is
directly from the teacher the
prophet Mohammad. The prophet
Muhammad is narrated to have
said. A kind word or even a
smile is a form of charity.
Serve muscles are walking
around smiling. It's because
you know we're being charitable
and if we're not. Tell us to
smile. We talk about we talk
you know we begin with we begin
with home we talk about our
neighbors- it there's a
tradition of the prophet
Muhammad that says. That you're
not a complete believer. Unless
you've ensured that forty of
your neighbors all of your
neighbors have. Been fed. And
so they went to the prophet
Muhammad and similar to other
religious traditions all they
would probably moms of any
neighbors at forty homes. Forty
homes I don't know forty my
neighbors and is going to be
honest with you. But not yet.
But but I mean that's that's
that's our tradition in fact.
There's so much in our in our
tradition around the rights. Of
neighbors. That of the
companions his his companions
later on said that the prophet
Muhammad would mention that are
the rights of neighbors so
much. That we thought they
would actually inherit from us
when we would pass- that's
that's when we talk about so
that's that's part of my
tradition and my religion now
of course. I can I can say so
much more but I'm I'm gonna
stop with that piece. As
Muslims up you know. Muslims
came to americana to what a lot
of people believe. Since came
to America with Columbus.
Muslims came to the Americas-
during slave trade to the all
of America's so we've been
here. For a very very long time
there's entire- books written
on this topic if you're
interested in reading about it
I can share some names with
you- a lot of the immigrant.
Push sort of came in the
fifties and sixties and
seventies. Where people like my
parents came out here- for you
know to get an education to. Be
a part of this community and
they made this land home. So
people still me sometimes and
think I don't speak a word of
English. I actually speak
English in about four one
accents and I do them all very
well. But what you know as so
you know our Moscow our mosque
in San Jose is operating our
fortieth anniversary next year
that's our fortieth formal
anniversary we've been around
for about five years. Before
that one of the things some of
the things that we do in our
community we get a lot of
community service health click
soup kitchens- if you come our
our sermons are on Friday
they're open to the entire
community we you know it's not
like. If someone else walks in
from a different community the
imam pulls out another sermon I
always joke about it right the
sermons are for everyone- and a
lot of what we discussed in our
sermons is community service is
compassion is mercy. Is how to.
Be kind to those around you
combine to even those who are
not kind to you in return
that's what my faith teaches
people- now. If some people of
my faith choose not to do that
you can't hold me responsible
for that- if. Certain media
outlet may want to cover
certain things in a different
way well there's only so much
that I can do. About that- but
you know the things any evil
act that's being done in the
world in in the name of my
faith or the name of any faith
for that matter anyone will
tell you that. That's not
correct- that's not how it's
going to be- yeah I know I told
you I wasn't a mom I take the
full thirteen minutes. You can
that's okay. I'm just gonna I'm
really quickly I'm gonna close-
up the hate crimes against
Muslims of course is not just
on a large scale in the United
States but believe in us
actually very heavily funded as
well lot of people don't
realize this there's risen
tire- research reports
statistics and I knew I to have
time for citing bring them but
if you go online and hate crime
funding against Muslims there's
an entire report out there
where this entire the
Islamophobia industry is
heavily funded by people living
right here. In the United
States of America- there was a
report released last week by
care and I saw some in here a
little while ago from care of
40% of Muslim students in
California report being bullied
because of their faith more
than twice the national average
for bullying in schools for all
students. Which is why many
Muslim families and I don't
think it's fair but many Muslim
families are choosing to
homeschool their children so
their children don't have to
face a lot of this and it's not
fair to the children- I'm I'm
gonna close I'm gonna close
with one quote from Henry David
Thoreau- he said it is never
too late to give up your-
business. Thank you very much.
Thank you. Among was his cells
of the lawmaker association and
actually have a die in fishers
who's a director of Jewish
community relations council of
Silicon Valley I am taking a
thank you assemblymember for
including me too and I think it
says something that all the
folks sitting here on know each
other and have a long history
of encouraging comparison in
our community. Of. So money
first thought and Piney this
request to talk about
compassion in the Jewish
community. Led me to revisit
the vigil for solidarity
against hate that we held in
front of St as a city hall.
Almost a year ago a and that
was in response to the shooting
of eleven people at the tree of
life synagogue in Pittsburgh.
And that image of so many
diverse faiths represented and
government. Everyone standing
in solidarity in mourning. And
in saying we are better than
that together was a very
profound expression of
compassion- and the ease some
of you may have seen aye sixty
minutes last Sunday for the
anniversary of this event there
was a piece on sixty minutes
and- the- we're showing them a
service at a synagogue. Where
any mom said just tell us where
you need us to be what do you
need us to do what do you need
so that you feel safe. Rate and
to me that's what this is about
right this is a an expression
of compassion is what what is
it take for kindness to be
expressed to affect someone
else's life. Eight and I think
this is what religion is about
trying to I don't think it's so
much about believe I think it's
about. Behaving in a
compassionate way- it's about
empathy and concern and justice
tolerance in fairness and
respect rate so even though
that the Jewish code of ethics
is based on a very well known
commandment love your neighbor
as yourself it's really not
about a motion rate it's a
commandment that's about.
Hannibal behavior in our
everyday lives. SO we have
individual acts of compassion
and these can combine into
communal compassionate-
accident in Jewish tradition.
Is considered important that we
be buried. Of at least in part
by our friends and family not
just by strangers right so we
have this tradition where you
actually. Difficult pick up a
shovel and participate in the
burial rate. He did the same
rate in the Muslim tradition
nay on and it's an ultimate act
of compassion because the
disease person can't repay the
effort to you right. On
providing healthcare is another
area that I thought about
because it's very deeply can
connected to compassion in in
Jewish tradition in many
traditions. My synagogue holds
a on. An annual health fair
that's usually at eastside
church every year where dozens
of doctors and nurses come and
provide free exams are
procedures- collaboration with
other health care providers
from other faith communities.
And another thing that came to
my mind was about a year ago I
visited at a hospital in Israel
in northern Israel where I
spoke with three Syrian man who
were there getting treatment on
the day had been injured in and
the fighting. In Syria they had
come to the border on to come
to the Israeli hospital so that
was an act of compassion it had
nothing to do with anything
else right. Thinking about the
on. Recent efforts by the
department of homeland security
to change the- the meaning and
effective public charge. People
than filing that rate nay the
which can that affect people's
ability to be admitted as
immigrants United States- which
fortunately has been
temporarily stopped by a
preliminary injunction but- I
thought about it a different
compassionate approach to
helping immigrants- that my
community- had which was-
keeper free loan. Rate about a
hundred years ago in Jewish
people were immigrating a
larger numbers to this country
on. He were free loan was
created so with that and people
could have a an interest free
loan to start a business or
adopt children or pay for
health care- you know get job
training them any kind of
emergency. And it was basically
advertises a alone for those
who need a hand up not a hand
out a that was the purpose and
my husband's grandparents- got
an interest free loan and
started a little a hardware
store in the Fillmore district
in San Francisco. And now we
have three generations of our
family that have continued to
thrive because of that act of
compassion. On something that's
it was an important example for
me. Some people we think that
legislating compassion is
perhaps it sounds like we're
trying to do is impossible but
even if I just look at my own
Jewish tradition it's clear.
That when we talk about kind is
give me live has said in Hebrew
it's a behavior that we say
everyone should engage in
whether you feel motivated to
do it or not Hey that's good or
not. The point ray- and in the
Hebrew Bible we- are we've
known to repeat thirty six
times some form of Dona press
the stranger rate. And the
rabbi say it's repeated because
it's really hard rate it's a
goal for us to treat people
that are different from
ourselves with compassion but
we need the reminder and I
think. This assembly resolution
on compassion is another
necessary reminder rate let's
let's just say this a lot and
often because we clearly in a
time when we need this reminder.
So where it work discussing
this compassion partly because
of Kern Armstrong's wish in two
thousand eight rate that. That
there's a charter for
compassion around the same time
Jeremy Rifkin read a book.
Titled the empathic
civilization and he wrote that
were software to experience
others feelings. Through mirror
neurons in our brains Hey we
have empathy because we
understand our own frailties
and we feel solidarity with
other people's vulnerability.
And the last ten years is in a
lot of research on the
assumptions of our human
nature. Rate on it shows that
we're not software to be
utilitarian and self interested
in materialistic rate. That
sociability an attachment.
Affection and empathy our our
key wiring so our government
and our families and our
businesses and our education.
They need to be in a re
oriented to it to be adapted.
To our focus center human
capacity for compassion. Our
cell phones in our
communication tools are often
considered to be like our big
down fall in our ability to be
compassionate but they also
function to bring more diverse
people together so in Jeremy
Rifkin's but he also talks
about what brought people into
empathic feelings for each
other. On and how that's
changed from ancient
civilizations till now so
compassionate aging times was
basically blood ties rate if
you really related to somebody
and then religious ties right
all Muslims feel tight and all
Jews held tight enough
Christians feel tied to each
other. And then we had national
identity ties rate Creek French
and German ties whatever rate
of that but now people have the
ability to empathize with
others that don't live near
them at all they don't. They
don't. Have the same religion
that don't even speak the same
language right you can use
Google translate and you can
talk to anybody anywhere in the
world. So we have individual
power to communicate with each
other without any kind of top
level controls mandating it we
have like distributed
compassion possibility. And
really at the end of our lives
it's that Ana empathic
connection to people which we
consider. To be the most
important thing we've done it
all in our time. So in light of
our current social ills I think
this focus on compassion also
needs to take. The form of
practicing tolerance for people
who. Think differently than
ourselves and particularly in
California we're gonna set a
trend this is important. S.
Hebrew word for tolerance is
sold là newt. It derives from
the words several which means.
To suffer so in other words we
have to injure a certain amount
of discomfort. To tolerate
people with different views ray
and Kern Armstrong also said
that a compassionate city one
of the things about it is it
needs to be an- uncomfortable.
City rate SB we just need to
accept that. Tolerance isn't
isn't just about acting kindly
to people that we believe are a
rung. It's also recognizing
that there might be some truth.
In positions that we disagree
with rate the Talmud teaches
that intellectual growth
depends on exposing yourself to
a variety of viewpoints a we
need to. To know about other
views with which we possibly do
we otherwise we have an
incomplete understanding. But
there's one. Thing that Jewish
tradition teaches. As where in
tolerance is a virtue. Which is
in opposition to someone who if
they gain power would deny
freedom to those with which
they disagree. So we should
stand strongly against anyone
using democracies tolerance for
an effort to overthrow it so I
think that in our current
situation this call for
compassion. Should be joined
together with a call to sustain
our democracy thanks. Thank you
thank you Diane I think you you
had the head of the nail right
beard see you know this
compassionate. A resolution is
really only serve as a reminder
you know we need to the
committee involvement we need
to religious leaders seem often
through the to move to our
state and the more
compassionate stay so it was
you really truly. A reminder
I'll also wanna thank you for
your- your work on the roof G.
settlement. I remember was Mike
my district staff was one one
day want to our office and
stuff a lot of back pack will
going back to school so thank
you very much for reaching out
to the community. And actually.
Have a father Joe home prodigal.
Father John is from a Catholic
charities of Santa Clara county.
Okay Sir thank you very much
for inviting me to speak to
this issue Margaret Mead was
asked. What was the signed the
first sign of civilization and
she responded the heel femur
he'll femur bone of the strong
his bones in the body but once
is broken it's very very
difficult and it makes it
income it it- percent Mendoza
prison unable to defend him or
herself they will need other
people the to care for them so
the early sign of a
civilization was actually
finding. A healed femur bone
because it presumes that the
people that were- with this
particular group of early
humanoids are bandied around
gathered around this individual
and care for the person just
put themselves in front of
danger to heal this person and
that fact that was healed that
person was was taking care for
a long time so that idea. Of
compassion is hard wired into
our species but it's also broke
in our by a deliberate design
decision to go against our
human nature what we see
happening right now. Hate
crimes increasing gets Latinos
are over 50% and I think that
you heard the mom to hear who'd
excused of for purposes a few
minutes- talked about the
increase in in hate crimes
against Muslims in the Jewish
to hate crimes increase 60% in
these- in the past two years of
the hate crime is not an
accident that is happening but
it's to the direct language
coming from the very top. So we
understand that I was just in
el Paso with bishop mark
science who signed a pastoral
letter linking and very clearly
showing the linkage between
hate language racism and border
policies and how that affects
people in el Paso he's a bishop
in el Paso he's he watched and
was walking with the people the
twenty three people that were
murdered- because of their race
and when we speak to people in
our community have gone to do
focus groups have gone to my
own membership and- different
groups around the county.
Income in this district that
people are saying that they now
for. Feel they are hunted
because of the color of their
skin and his identifies Latinos.
This is coming on the heels
what law in the Latino
community in the Catholic
outlet here community they see
these these ideas of a public
charge they see these are the
separation of our family the
border. Over the phone into
cages are at the their
deliberately top being targeted
by these policies and by the
language- and children are very
very aware of what's happening.
I to them and because of that
we want to I just want to say
this very clearly because I
know speaking as a is there a
question in all of this and I.
Come out of the Catholic
tradition but- since I was
Reyes Buddhist and my dad was a
Protestant and I became
Catholic- I think I can speak
on a three ecumenical
experience. Level experience a
level- and hang out with a lot
of my friends are Jewish that
are going to Buddhist things
and other Sufi things so I
having a lot of these very
strange friends. But the idea
what I do one is. So strange
you know but I think.
Substituting but with these
guys up here but I think where
the people are. The whole going
on. But I think that what you
we is people of faith. I did
exception that. Leadership of
at the very highest levels are
co opting religious language.
As a way to justify hatred. And
then activity even with those
who are Christian. That we know
that within in their Christian
ranks. There are a number of
people that agree with these
policies. That see nothing
wrong with. Putting children in
cages they see nothing wrong
with. A taking away health
care. Of from families in need.
And they see nothing wrong with
ignoring the Fourteenth
Amendment which gives every.
Person living in the United
States and any of its
territories. The same due
process and everybody else.
That we they they forget that
there's a constitutional
reality. And they're willing to
overlook that and overlook all
the- evo all these kinds of
things and so I called my
Christian brothers and sisters.
Who may be in this room but
certainly to let you. Know
that- that we came out of. You
out of it out of a Jewish
context. And so we have
inherited a rich tradition of
what Dianne just finished
speaking about of course said
of loving kindness. Of loving
mercy of living that out in
faith we can't do that so out
of Christian Christian
scriptures have to be
understood in the context of
what is it mean. To reflect on
the Torah on the law of god
love more. Is revealed to Moses
and that we and all of our
teachings come out of the idea
that. That in are there is no
distinction of male female
slave or free that we are all
one it doesn't make that
difference so that that makes
it very clear that this
question of. Separate bathrooms
is ninety and you can't use
that is a it from a Christian
perspective I think you can
think you are but you clearly
when you look at scripture.
Once and such strong ground the
other ideas at that in if even
within Christian scripture
speaks of salvation is being.
Everyone gathered around the
one throne of god and the lamb
of god they identified as
Christ Jesus. That at around
that lamb of god in this kind
of idea this. Powerful imagery
it is all nations gather
regardless of race tried nation
and people that they're all
gather together and seeing each
other as one. Again so with in
the Christian tradition there
is. A sense of racial equality
there is no sense of separation
superiority and lastly- the
historically asistir lanes now
speaking of the character
historical tradition. We have
always been a church of
immigrants so we came over as
immigrants ourselves- most of
the of the priest of the dice
is a San Jose or immigrants
very few were actually native
born the from. India the from
different countries in Africa
they're from different
countries and Spanish speaking
America's- Europe and all
throughout Asia. So we is a
Catholic Church in this diocese.
You know are not just video of
a church of immigrants your
church that is solidly walking
with him in immigrants. In it
is specifically of those were
the most broken most vulnerable
to these policies. And there's
a language that has victimized-
our people. Are lastly we talk
about the idea of some of the
as a victim. Of violence then
that that you know we used to
think there's only two choices
when you're silent victim you
just take it. Your strong you
move on that's my mother's
Japanese tradition that you
know you just. All the things
that happened her folks the her
people I'm that you just. Yo
you just move ahead. And you
move ahead was silent and
steely determination. But not
everybody how's that and once
that is an option. To and the
other thing that we don't want
the people have another option
they think is just being an
object of someone else's
charity well at the
legislators. Make a rule for us
will make will have a grant
finder give us some money will
have some teacher some other
institution speak for us. And
that's wrong. Because people
are to speak for themselves.
And so that the job of the
religious community is
certainly in my experience. Is
that we need to create that
space for those who are
directly affected those were
directly. Beaten by these kinds
of policies this kind of
language and physically
attacked because of their race
their gender identity this
sexual orientation or their
religious affiliation because-
these are the people that need
to be at the table to speak and
views the people that need to
be the cages. Tables that make
those decisions about what does
it mean to be compassionate.
Because IT. You can pass as
white I'm not white but I can
pass a sense all day get you
know sure. But you know what.
Not everybody that can pass by.
Not everybody can enjoy the
certain privileges. And so that
our belief at least in for our
Calvet tradition is that people
we need to create that space
for people to speak directly
from their experience we but
we- have a- verse that we- we-
we understand is. God hears our
cries the poor some thirty
four. Or thirty three diverse
aye account by the to that this
idea is that. You god is
hearing the cries the poor and
therefore it is incumbent upon
those who call themselves
allegiance to god or people of
god. They must also here these
very same crises. They can't go
empty into the desert. So
creating space means this and
it's a simple theology- that we
are getting from- that we
receive is Catholics. From a
pope Francis who leads us by
example and by. By by
encouraging. Not just Catholics
but people of all good will is
that creating space means you
quite in if you increase the
space for listening. Encuentro
and that is really that the
mutually. Transformative
experience of listening to
another person creating that
space for that. That story that
narrative to be told and that
means that we have to step
back. And recover the art of
listening and stop the dialogue
in. In in in in tweets are in
income will silly remarks. My
roommate making finger gestures
from the earth to the moon
whatever I mean you can't do
those things without stopping
and listening and creating that
space. For an interpersonal.
Connection to happen so our
methodology at least I'm
working with a group that's
working on the methodology of
encuentra that is mutually
counter we're we listen and
those who have that. Have
privilege don't talk about the
privilege but they simply
listen. They become aware of
who they are and who space they
walk and we're aware of the
land. On a who. You on a who we
occupy we occupy the because
stone's we occupy the Aloni we
occupy the met various
different me walk the various
different. Communities and
nations that there on this land
we are inherently wear that and
we're connected to the planet
were connected to listening and
so that encuentra. Is that
dialogue that begins in
listening and humbleness of you
where people are in their lives
and that experience with calls
is solidarity or celebrity
that. That experience a
solidity that of solidarity
weakens in us we call continues
us you own. A wakening and not
just awareness but a
commitment. To continuing that
dialogue. And so for- for from
my perspective fact I think
that and I. One minute. Okay
thank our get sick as a priest
in go on forever but I won't-
but but I want to talk about
the idea of solidarity because
that's ultimately what we're
all call to do in terms of
creating compassion and
solidarity is it just as a
stance in your head or-
ideological perspective it is
actually putting our bodies.
Next to other people our bodies
are in solidarity not our minds
on if not a theology not our
ideology and it's not about
**** by ya. It is about true
honest commitment of walking
with feeling empathizing and
making it your because as well
as I think that the piece in
terms of faith me that's the
work that we're trying to do we
do that in a bunch of different
kind of zip codes where we were
as Catholic charities we work.
With our agent we work with
rather with our clients we
trick train those who work with
the people are case workers a
case managers it is all about
that listing and accompanying
an individual. No matter what's
happened that compassion has to
flow from our humidity at that
comes from the fact that we
have a heel femur in our
ancestor and that he'll teamer.
Has to be handed down from
generation to generation. Thank
you thank you very much. Of the
John. Does want to take a- few
minutes to. Go over some
housekeeping I can. And do will
be time for public comment at
the end. And for those in the
audience that would like to
make a public comment. Please
raise your hand and one of my
staff can provide you with the
car. Views me. Thank you now-
moving on to- Jewish shop from
the- the cofounder of the chain
center. And all of northern
California by hearing in milk
this. Cherish. Okay. In the
technology world you always
have to line. Thank you again
for inviting me. I I'm going to
talk a little bit of our to our
fate because most people who
may not know all what Chen is a
means. And what we believe. And
there is the freight the green
we live in. The twine with
compassion no the principles
are really. Intel integrated
into our belief system so I
will talk about a little so you
can understand that I come from.
A Chen community is a very
small community. Even in India
it is less than 1% of end of
population. In America is about
the same. And all we are about
two hundred thousand James in
North America US and Canada.
And here in the bay area we
probably are about. Twenty five
hundred families that are part
of heart. Number here in may be
this. So we don't experience
all the different problems that
other communities of experience
because we are invisible. And
of course in of pecan del Rio
in a Jan because we looked like
any other Indian or any other a
in in America so. It's kind of
difficult. But we Chen said
later the lenders contribution
to India and its culture. Far
beyond is numbers. In all kinds
of situations are open and
culturally economically
everything a charity Gen seven
to the forefront in India. En
route to a trying to emulate
dot over here by being generous
in the community. So what does
it bring back to those who do
not much margin ism. I like to
say that. Journalism arose from
pension prehistorical time in
India. That I've never twenty
four forty quality. Operators
of human in all nay in nature
the born human and the victims
the end and they became
probably it'll journalism op
that the twenty to thirty the-
program which is impossible.
Not was about eight hundred and
fifty BC. My average of the
twenty fourth. Teachings often
followed now are was six
hundred BC and this tool. At
the moment was not it is have
been accepted by historians as
historical people so that they
exist at and they'll drone the
land of India. Even though I
llama is all in of the lie là
my knees book for as a group
conserve afraid describe
Jenny's on. As it principally
of. Buddhism. Because more Chen
is up some photos from what is
known as Camelot division of.
That was they have a long long
time. Many of our principles
are similar. Journalism is a
way of life. It's a philosophy
and a way of life. We don't
have a god creator. Because you
believe the universe of exist a
four hour and continues to
exist. Nothing gets destroyed
nothing gets created in the
works. Hands. Which survey of
life and is driven by the
beauty of karma. That you saw
watch hello you reach such a
saw. And that that is how we
have always constantly to be.
At our best because anything
that we do is going to come
back to haunt him. For
thousands of years Gen certain
practicing vegetarianism about
meditation and the environment.
James believing that those old
bridges o'donnell and divine we
believe which are sold as a
Donald and divine. By the way
there is no sections. So does
have a sex so what we have is a
body solo plaza body when it
takes both. Sometimes you might
get a female parties under the
main body sometimes you get a
neutral party. In a transgender.
But we also recognize that
beyond the physical body which
is. Which you get based on your
he got the karma. Or nam karma.
There is actually a mental
state. And so you could have a
physical he in all male body
but your mental state because
of your of karma the type of
for my dad did delude in
government. You could have a
female magic. And that's what
so we recognize that there is a
difference between the mind set
or room in the inclination
reverses the physical body you
up. Which means that you should
be looking at if I look at you
grandson and say oh grandson is
Chinese American. I have
committed issues crime. I
should be seeing you as Kansen
Chu Ái servicing as a
soldier. Has loan Reyes there
there's no. No collar low S.
sex nothing at all so moment
think of someone else other.
You are actually. Driving that
violence on the person. And of
course is that violence is on
your part and we believe that
violence of talked is equally
bad as violence of actual
physical one. Because we
believe not harming himself or
non violence is by after a
speech and by thought. And all
of them have to be controlled
by you. A three ton that's that
we have is the second one is
under god what or multi
procedural viewpoint. And I
call that as a non while of
talked. Because in our view on
the multiplicity of viewpoints.
Look and think about the
other's point of view. Muscles
point of view were the same.
And by looking at others point
of view you may see something
different life altogether. And
that makes two thousand
actually the word tolerance is
not as Burke as acceptance we
call it you have to accept the
other stocks because there may
be some. Faith in its on
putting it and you have to find
that. Silicon Albright discard
a by because of principle of an
icon. The other one of course
is. Of non possessiveness and
I'm not gonna talk about Medina
long position that which we
have but Paul just a mental
long possessiveness. Attachment
to your children is mental
possessiveness. Attachment to
or hate to someone else is a
mentor possessiveness. It's it
is your mental this implies
that you have to control so
that you would not be affected
by your. The very important
part of Chen philosophy is
forgiveness and I want to read
something one of our aphorism.
Is commonly so would you agree
so would you recommend to me.
The missile will borders so.
Number John McKenzie. Everybody
in the store that. I forgave
all of the all beings may all
living beings brown who
forgiveness. My friendship as
with all living beings I have
no animosity towards any that's
what the effort as a means. It
truly says I am asking and this
is the this aphorism is
practical. Saved by. The
challenge the bill Jones are
overlap baptising Gaines.
Almost every single day. To do
mind you constantly that you
have to ask for forgiveness you
have to give forgiveness and
forget and you should be
friendly with everyone and you
should. Not have any enemies I
would go on to that is. Another
row. I will keep my time I
think I better not so bad this
forgiveness will destroy hatred
and fear. When you forgive
somebody you can no longer hate.
And possibly forgiving and also
the Skinner forgiveness which
we do. With a worse for me
Charlie but I'm- and I'm sure
you heard some of those books.
Which means that I'm asking for
part excuse. For give me
because I have done something
wrong. Joint committee is as I
was saying is a small committee
is a charitable committee does
a lot of chatter W. unknown
projects in India. He had even
our youth will all to serve
those at the shelter. The
global serve the homeless. And
we encourage our children to.
Participate but you know
because our Sunday school
children. And we're getting to
get involved in too many of the
activities not as many as I
like. But because of the
numbers are small and many of
our people have come recently
H. one B. visa guys so they
hadn't that that here for sort
of trying. To has of course I
have been here fifty sixty
hours so I have seen this. Land
here change and this is home.
Never talk about the concurrent
resolution a one oh eight. This
is the resolution that we need
to have an adoption I am very
happy glad that are. Eminem the
member Kansen Chu has taken
that and- for that resolution
up. Any of the community like
is a free will and others have
signed on. Site because time
and I county also has signed on
toward ambassadors and adapted
confirmed. And I'm also
represent Silicon Valley
interreligious counselor the
war wise chair and we have been
part of that effort. Promote
people adopt a charter for a
charter for compassion. What
this will do is it'll become a
lighting roar lightning roar to
everybody in the community in
the California. Because once it
is state is his added
compassionate state everybody
will want to get on the band.
And high hopes that enable to
encourage them to get on the
background and signed the
combatant compassion and become
compassionate not just by name.
Because you would have to that
act accordingly. Your a all of
the laws you may have to be
judge by the measure of
compassion and on maybe
compassion index or something
like that that we create so the
region's matted like the tried
each item back stashed in a
statement that. Many of the
copies half. Those indexes can
be created and we can see on
the truly compassionate.
There's actually a study by
city alluvial. Did they did
what is a compassionate index
and they started all the
different districts to see how
compassionate bill there and we
will look into it after. Your
resolution is passed to see how
that technology. That
methodology can help us.
Measure compassion that is and
measure the change that happens.
In my opinion the get income in
California as a compassionate
state will foster cultural
compaction compassionate action
and talk so if you want to
create a culture of
compassionate action promoting
friendliness among California
residents which will help us
all current community.
Challenges we have a blank
compassion games the lastly I
want to recommend I recommend a
couple things first include
forgiveness and compassion
training in schools I non black
non religious basis children
should learn forgiveness right
from the charter. Rear tires
I'm also the board member of
getting the vision-
organization and V. remote
mindfulness and live still
living in skilled rise scores
of some of the schools in South
Bay. And children not very
happy doing five minutes of
meditation in the morning and
the results are. Absolutely of
a sky in terms of the behavior
and up so there so we should
promote second is modernize
forums to promote. Compassion
and forgiveness and general
public periodically. And my
third is that view to create a
measure compassionate such as
index for different counties in
California. Thank you. Thank
you very much interest your but.
Next we'll move to. Rajiv our
our. Under rare Iago for over
you are you all use a podium it
Ohara. Okay. No beer is was to
seek coalition. Thank you
right- so of thank you for
having me here. I am the best
thing of I am not a religious
let leader by any measure. I am
actually a volunteer with
sickle Rhaetian and also a
member of a grassroots level
team that we founded in city of
Fremont to deal with the
backlash. Of that we felt after
nine eleven and I have a co
founders of the team in my room
and in the room as well. In our
eyes I'm standing. Because I.
I'm used to talking what step
out. I I'm a software engineer
so I just feel lost if I'm
talking with a slight so that
you will see some slides. And
I'm also a college. As of
another reason to have slides
up the right. Plus I can see
you- that it is so wonderful to
see all the young faces initial
the students this is this is
the next generation of
Americans that it at this heart
warming to see them here and
actually listen in. At and be
part of this. Let me begin with
a heartfelt thanks to. The
Assemblymembers. The brain
behind issue out of one oh
eight and the co authors of one
it. I would also like to room
extend my thanks to. All the
people who have worked behind
behind the scenes on this this
is this is not something that
can be done easily. Hey and I'm
looking forward to the day of
an S. C. R. well no it does get
passed and it helps us to a
point where we can say. For me
a second. As the. California
usually is all and- select
decision for each each no we
met him in another it's not.
Shop did. It's to give you a
quick overview of who six are
because not everybody knows who
six are the- even though in in
the bay area visit believe
there seem to be a lot because
of that our months. But there
are very few six of in terms of
percentage of population if you
look at a number of the
demographics nationwide even in
India. Get six for less than 2%
of the population. So what.
What okay judge. Okay am I
doing anything okay there is
there's just a lack. All right.
Okay so of. Six sick ism- is it
it has compassion in grand into
stagings in so many ways of
that- it is hard to explain it
in a few words. The compassion
that was exemplified by founder
of the faith who we call a
good- the word good who has a
very special meaning for six
it's not an export of some kind
in a subject matter Google
means a person who shows you
the way throughout your life.
The person who enlightens your
path. So when you his sit here
lower good in the sick contacts
please please. Take note of the
distinction so compassion was
exemplified by the thick crews
in my many ways it is built
into the golden rules of the
sick faith. The six prayer the
daily six prayer actually ends
with the asking for well being
of all. All humans all creation.
Get six plus the worship which
are known as good a daughters
we have a good but I had a
movie does a go to the three
mile island Santa. Ana the
liberalism of the- they also
this. Nothing. Six open in
California for well over a
century the earliest written
records that you can find a
date back to eighteen nineties.
The. Six cam- on that nine at
nineteen please most of them it
will working on- maples bill
roads and also. Yes special
instead. All orders in the US.
Starting it one four ohms
allied allied. Right. Twenty
six also stopped coming to come
especially cal. Number eighty
four high. And one of the six
who. Cal and get it is with the
map the night twenty two. M.
well in to the US Congress it
is the thing so. He joined us
in nineteen fifty Scott back to
twice that. Ready for six good.
Built in North America. For me
it's in the of Stockton is not
far from. Nineteen who need to
the landmark. Six how had
humble beginnings in our state
but for the spear entry have a
held many use for. Bob the con.
Farming. Health says you can
tech unit you find six it in
the in those fields. Sec Israel
was founded by good- Nanak in
late fifteenth century. He
himself was an embodiment of
compassion and I'll talk more
about that he traveled far and
wide to tell in fits .org with.
It's of time especially in Asia.
The cosmetic model to Grisham
believe that one vote for all
creation. The three rules the
kids are bush got. For the
presence of time some of the
service to manage. Our
livelihood being self reliant.
The basic believe of Sikhism in
the universal equality is
taught in so many different
ways. And it also the opening
percent in in Tikrit. Six
script. Two one AM but there's
act regardless of care the car
of Conor cam. Gender so numb
and out. If you take a look at
the prospect of ticket welcome
to be a. Eight fifteen three it
was. On the forefront address.
The ones. Specially in and out
part of the but at the time.
House better it meant a woman
woman. Three three. And before
yes it needed. Also and also
lead. This is. Six even
proselytize. But he got it.
Because the focus is on your
inner self. Jones who you are
and tried most others it the
focus it is in word you work on
yourself I'd be a better human
be a better six. Good Nanak who
is the founder of the faith- we
are. This six are waiting.
Celebrate his. Month. He was a
pioneer in the field pollution
hello. Yeah the most. But
here's the early. Leave of its
weather is. But this. Strong
against. And. What is of vote.
Hello the privileged. For okay
Ste. He was a tent. He was a
particular song that her father.
Men and of the. To be pious
hope for. And being harmed
trying to run away from. Sec.
Please please and Ste yes. His
teachings. One five nine group
in here. And the good. To the
right things to go. You know it
when you're scared itself
became the guru for L. if you.
Hey going to see at the
scripted itself being the set
the focus of attention because
that is the good. In a few
words is that of- projected
here just to show up. Compare
the six. What thirty things.
The words of good luck but he's
okay game. Bob barber what the
founder move anise India and
Weber. The study. Thanks yes.
Is what. It was launched
writings it is a but Barbara.
At. Or the other mercy. The
first from the sacred scripture.
This is again from- non ECC he
is saying a woman should be
treated as less than men what
is one who was forced to the
mall. Whether there or what
there's. Are you want to buy
your book. To be less than a
minute. From fifty two. This.
An easy law but his in his his.
I don't see any. He's hold no
malice against anyone. Of
vernacular overlap actually
share the view. The school like.
Dodd right double the saw motor
he. They got a total tongue but.
How many I'll six compassionate
be lovely. Nine give his life
what. By he. He was given first
it too at the field all. Also
appears but and miss hello my
toes well. Thank you for being
a most. Who would have. For
seventy years after two four
seven when India order is get
better than it used that Irving
thousands. Earning top again.
Teacher. Okay other examples
off all six of practice
compassion in modern times.
There are countless examples
that tell inspired state to be
more loving care. How we I
don't think so we can lot for.
He need to take a step a strong
hand. How is the are one past
my call affection to. Other
than my sisters and I am in the
room is the got all over this
we need all of them. And have
them call. The rest of the
members and is here one. We can
help look up first compassion
US thank you. Thank you very.
Last but not least we have the
can do a mereka and foundation
points north in California
chapter Raji you've seen. Good
evening and I must say thank
you namaste. Thank you assembly
member Chiu for a giving us
this. Opportunity and
organizing the event. While I'm
here representing him the
American foundation as you said
I'm also representing the wider
into our community only in
California but also nationwide-
I want to take the opportunity
to also thank assembly members
bloom Burke Kalra lackey and
however for co authoring the
resolution. Thank you in
CinemaCon Reyes here. I'll be a
little more scripted- than
other presenters because I'm
presenting about five thousand
years of story of come
compassion here. So that said
as a Hindu I'm glad to report
that I can share more than one
definition often those.
Regardless of which ever
narrative you choose- to
remember your discover that
Hinduism means many
philosophies and schools of
thought many forms to express
these thoughts. And a rich
tapestry of human values. The
more Hindus he will meet the
more you realize that there is
not one but numerous numerous
bats practices and piety there
is no one perfect way our world.
In fact we embrace in perfect
because it lands us an
opportunity to understand the
world around us. Now if I were
to tell you the same story but
in reverse order. The narrative
will be something like this.
There are people in this world
who are comfortable with this
imperfect world that we live in.
Either through their own
natural constitution. All
through the observation of the
richness of the creation around
us they have come to respect
the different avenues people
have historically taken. To
understand the world around
them. The trace this open an
acceptance of parts to overturn
lainnya. Too many texts art
forms lower and practices.
These other hinders. And that
is pluralism I believe off the
COR offended them all beings
from the smallest organism man
are considered manifestations
of the divine or deflections of
Devine's qualities. Because of
this shared divinity in those
views the universe as the
family or as in Sanskrit we say
it must've they've become. The
Hindu world has been able to
embrace the reality of
diversity and relish and
religious freedom through its
philosophy of pluralism. Every
being with their varying likes
and dislikes their own unique
personalities and different
cultures normally connect with
one another in their own unique
ways. But connect with the wind
in their own individual way.
This embrace of tourism has
taken contributed to the
incredible spiritual and
religious freedom. One
witnesses within Hinduism which
often confuses up people in the
west. The word pluralism is not
just acceptable to Hindus but
all members of universal family
accordingly does it make
knowledge is not just the
possibility but also the
existence of more than one path.
Or way of really into the truth
bath being religion and truth
being caught. This is true on
adulterated pluralism is
captured in the ancient
Sanskrit pan which are will
translate in English that says
truth is one the wise call it
by the names. It doesn't matter
which direction narrative of
Hinduism. Fix your interest
what you're likely to discover
is that none of the diversity
and richness and in the
tradition would have been
possible without respect. Not
mere tolerance but respect. And
then you will discover the
substrate underneath all of
this which is compassion that
Hindus have not only for us but
for every life form around us
in fact comparison isn't
grained in the ultimate goal of
every- moksha or freedom from
the cycle of birth and rebirth
is characterized by the
overcoming of spiritual
ignorance the complete
elimination of material desires
and attachments the affected
ability to live in the present
moment. And XP is absolute
peace. Most importantly the
awakening of your compassion
towards all. Dianne talked
about the progression of a bit
earlier off- blood ties to
religious ties to natural ties
it by under sorted right. One
man. Took that advice. Many
many years ago and created one
of the biggest moments which we
today because the Gandhi's.
Still rights disobedience
moment which was non violent.
And he then also influenced.
Outside of his nation to the
global war people like Dr king
to take on with the same
compassion the biggest
challenges that he faced in his
time and his people face for
many many. Centuries before
that. See this is what we
cannot. Get him while we are
here in California is the
California's biggest story of
compassion right here at home.
I hình saw or non violence. Is
one of the most important
pillars of Hindu philosophy.
Concept of a hand size deeply
embedded in the videos the
engine in the pictures which
proposed that all beings from
the smallest optimism man
Acosta manifestations of god
and members of universal
family. This word view what
plans and talked. Words he'd
against a living being is
contrary to the natural balance
of this universe. Not just
physical violence but violence
in fought and. And even that
the. The spirituality is a more
by the Hindus. Compassion is a
psychological construct that
day let hate to situate in a
society. But the question still
remains which is how do we
spread compassion.
Compassionate California's
announced that. It encourages
us to improve the lives of all
can only a residents. And treat
them with dignity the
consistently and emphatically
to frame from inflicting pain
to act or speak violently out
of spite or self interest
towards any of the being or
group of beings. Impoverishing
exploit or deny basic rights to
anybody and to incite hatred by
denigrating others these are
not my words these are the
works. Of the resolution that
you folks have written great
profound words compassionate
club California. Is the and in
the sale of organizations.
American foundation that amber
pretending here today. That is
a gazed in efforts to bring
justice to victims of hate
crime. Working to stop bullying
in schools. Acting bias in
textbooks and promoting human
rights and religious freedom.
Weakened them and work against
hatred violence and
discrimination against all
community. That's why we've we
proud to work with us remember
choose office on important
pieces of hate crime
legislation here in California
that make all communities safer
to strengthen. Hate crime
protection assembly bill three
hundred. Accuracy in reporting
of hate crimes and incidents
and assembly bill one zero five
two. Require peace officers to
and- comprehensive training on
hate crimes to better identify
and respond to hate crimes.
Then you also talked about
legislating compassion. Earlier
our new use the word impossible
or difficult but something
along those lines. But I think
that's only half of the
equation. Even if we manage to
legislate compassion which I
think we are sincerely wanting
to do that's what I'm sensing
the. With the with the strength
in which we have shown up. The
young people that I think is
the future of California I
think will be successful in it.
We have to promote a culture of
compassion. It is the only
sensible approach to making
such a diverse collection of
people have in California a
place that is safe peaceful and
welcoming. But compassion is
more than just. About being
able to call up a home and feel
safe and secure. A bigger
outcome of compassion. Is the
diversity dividend. Which we
are already reaping hearings at
in Silicon Valley. But we have
a bigger opportunity in front
of us so even if you are not a
person who believes in combat
is an out of. Compassion out of
spirituality if you are
business minded person
capitalist a hardcore
capitalist. There is a story of
compassionate California that
only propel us even farther
father had. On the global
economic index if they were to
be one. Hindus have a thousand
a few thousand years of history
to share as evidence-
compassion is not a political
necessity it doesn't exist
existentialists yesterday. And
then. About a billion of us who
can tell you that it works. So
with that thank you again for
the opportunity thank you
assembly members and thank you
for all the- Dahle staff for
making this possible. Thank you
thank you so much. The thank
you for the D. percent through
the two distinguished panelists
your feedback and
recommendations are specially
valuable as you understand.
What our community needs you
know we have about twenty
minutes- sure okay how how long
can we keep this room. So don't
get don't do many ideas. All
right so I know we have some
high school students and- they
have some comments or questions
so before we can go back to the
dais can we ask of high school
students to come up first you
can make your common you're
welcome to stay as long as you
can. Or you go home and finish
your homework. So we. I
understand that you have some
prepared comments so feel free
to come up it. To the to the
podium. Uhhuh working right now
.
Hello of my name's Kristy park
and I'm originally eerie and
we're from archbishop many high
school representing the midi
advocacy project our schools
student run social justice
advocacy club on thank you so
much for having us here and to
his Chen for inviting us of
it's really great opportunity
of end we think that a ACR one
away is really great because it
perfectly aligns with our
mission of creating a
compassionate community- one
bond and empathy and okay
understanding- and as father
John in ms Fisher talked about
creating a- space for open
dialogue. And that's one of the
things that we really pursued
during our of time that maybe
because we've invited speakers
such as the National Alliance
on mental illness as well as
the Brady campaign now
participated in strikes such as
the climate strike out and
we've created all these
opportunities because we think
it's really important to create
a space thoughts open to so
many different perspectives-
and to have the opportunity. To
gain a more holistic
understanding of our community.
Yeah and that's why we believe
that the guidance that would be
foster under having a community
of compassion and having such a
framework would be so important
especially in the regime of you
know building more supportive
and compassionate communities.
So in light of this initiative
we've come up with a couple of
ideas for tangible Paul
implementation to back having
this statute of the theoretical
resolution. So our first idea
is to integrate more hate crime
prevention training within
school the school curriculum-
starting all the way from
kindergarten up to senior year
of high school. So last year
actually in my junior year I'm
a senior currently of I took a
social justice class and one of
the units that was the most
impactful for me was a unit on
implicit bias. And so basically
what we did during that time
was we took a couple of test
that pinpointed specific our
biases. Thought were I guess
intrinsic within our
perspective the I wasn't even
aware about. And I think
thought was a prime of moment
for me in shaping and I guess I
understanding where I was
coming from and understanding
the people around me. And so in
light of that we are think side
integrating more training on
hate crime prevention within
schools- such as activities
Taylor to grade levels such as
addressing stereo types in
decreasing the casual
integration of. Racial slurs
or- name calling and students
everyday vernacular that's just
way too casual to be correct of
would be of. Important first
step to take. And we also want
to emphasize the need for
awareness both in our community
through local events or even in
libraries like through the
research that we've done we
found that. This violence
against Pacific communities
especially minority communities
is gotten so common that it's
become normal and as I'm sure
everyone knows that this is not
normal and it's not okay. And
this is especially the case
because individuals don't have
the needed resources or access
to the kind of community
atmosphere that they require to
have the resolutions to these.
Hate crimes both in the in a
workplace or even on just a
regular cat colloquial level
like Christy talked about- and
that's why I'm gonna awareness
we feel like we should have. A
repeal or even a redefinition
of for by which is which stands
for the federal education
rights and privacy act and
it's- so the statue like. You
to remote privacy among school
communities it actually makes
it's almost impossible for
individuals to come forward
when they have experience hate
crimes and it's especially
important in the school context
for youth like us. Because as
we've seen first hand in other
schools other communities
school resource officers often
criminalize individuals Ashley
minority youth for the most
menial I'm kind of infractions.
And it's this kind of
legislation that prevents
individuals from coming forward
to talk about the violence in
the communities and be able to
vocalize that this is in fact
not what we as a community
should or need to stand for.
And. We think that having this
framework of having this. For
compassion within California is
so importance because a it's
necessary to get rid of this
kind of stigma for help seeking
and the ability for individuals
to come forward and promote.
More representation both in
front of. In front of audiences
as well as creates a better
community for everyone to feel
embraced. Great thank you very
much. Well to more through them
from meeting high school.
Please come forward. And to
have any limitation on the
public comment. Two minutes.
Okay. Hello everyone all our
names are issued by the north
and mobile auger wall and-
we're also from the media
advocacy project on under the
policy consultants for this
area but so we also agree with
the- compassion for the- the
mandate for compassion but we
believe that in order to of all
this like a review and-
Christie said we need to have
some concrete legislation so we
have a few different ideas for
this so one of our ideas about
per people funding so
California's spending billions
of dollars and recently I read
on the news that Gavin Newsom
is going to sign one of the
biggest- federal or state
mandates for education in the
history of California. However
something that we thought was
like kind of striking was that
the per pupil funding
specifically is limited so what
we think is that the per pupil
funding should be expanded
because what's going on right
now is that schools aren't able
to find out orange is specially
cam low income schools in like
low income areas aren't able to
find an adequately provide the
education and resources needed
to foster like a safe
educational learning
environment so that's why we
think if we increase per pupil
funding that can foster a
better educational environment
for these children to succeed
I'm and learn I'm also teachers
lack the available resources in
order to create search safe
environment so. By increasing
per pupil funding we think that
these teachers will be a better
able to stir such safe and
environments and further
different forms. Of education
that a reaching Christy were
talking about. So in addition
another thing that believes is
that school funding should not
be biased towards a high income
areas. However on the certain
policies that are in place
right now seem to be leaning
towards these ideas. Currently
many low income schools in
areas of several students are
not able to go to- school as
often because they have less
income. And that's why we're
seeing right now that there-
school absenteeism in the lower
income areas are it is around
13% compared to four percent.
In areas with our well I'm I'm
Bridger hoods and so this
causes a sort of a vicious
cycle in which- the people who
are that these people are less
incentivized to go to school in
the first place. Because of the
fact that our current system it
funds the schools based on the
attendance a not the actual-
enrollment in the school which
means the overall less people
are incentivized to go to
school in the first place.
Since there's less funding as
the absenteeism and this
creates a sort of cycle when
which blessed people a less and
less people go to school in
these low income areas. So we
believe that we should be able
to stop this by making it based
on enrollment. And not based
on. The of the of amount of
attendance in the school. So
just to close off map firmly
believes that the compassion a
resolution should be supported
and it'll be in it would play a
key role in the-
implementations of. Several
programs throughout. The state
and- you be unifying force
among schools and also greeting
California is one of the first
compassionate states would
serve as a good model not only
for California but- I think for
the country as well. Proving
that we are compassionate and
we do truly care about our
neighbors and the people around
us so. Thank you for your time
again and- thank you. Yeah
right. Thank you very much.
More students for have public
comment or questions. Please
come forward okay your welcome
to state and if you have
homework to do you make sure
you finish it tonight for you
go to bat or- I I'm also
debating you know because I
know that after the
presentation of my colleagues
here in the dais might have
some questions or comment to
may or. Sure we you the time
for the. Poll on the audience
who I have the of quite a
number of cars that. They have
they have common to our country.
You are you I'm I know I'm
trying to get some consensus I
thought this is ready if
president Reagan- ready to
make. We can do calm and not
questions we used them and then
they can do follow up after
they are questions whether
there. Are at least everyone
gets a chance to including the
public. Okay great. Okay
because the way have about ten
minutes left that's why I am
debating. Okay let's so let's
go to of public common error
and before I do that I also
want to recognize who wore. A
president trump you haven
unified school district. It was
the suit Sir rob jet car Chiu
most here with- heard two
wonderful it's a children. So
thank you very much. And this
is the of I don't know in the
ordered- we have- but I would
like to call to media loose men
from console of American
Islamic group relationship
care. To come for. This a
similar issue in the room she's
coming up. Okay and the next
one I like throughout. The
state and from and double ECP.
To come up and you use one of.
Hello I'm again my name is
Salinas mon on the government
relations coordinator for care
thank you so much again for
having this panel- on- you know
the interface- community and
also discussing- hate crimes-
what our organization does that
we provide free legal services
to- people who have been facing
any Islamophobic discrimination
and hate crimes. School
bullying law enforcement
harassment and also now we're
offering- immigration services
as well- we have seen the new
year after year- a number of
cases that have come into our
office almost a thousand-
Acosta California of total
civil rights cases- but we've
also- received about a hundred
and thirteen. Cases dealing
specifically with hate crimes
or hate incidences- and- you
know people have been- we've
been seeing a lot of these
cases especially- so after the
press or leading up to the
presidential election and after
the presidential election and
it has- also extended into the
workplace is sick Elsa extended
into the schools. I'm a mom
thought he had mentioned report
that we just recently put out-
of a survey that place of-
about fifteen hundred students
across California asking them
what their experiences are in
school and we found that again
40% of them had said that they
had experienced some form. Of
bowling in not only from-
fellow students but also from
their teachers and that is
really concerned so that's why
we had worked with- the
assembly and actually work with
a- to. A two bills the safe
place to learn act one that
would provide- school site and
online resources to deal with
bowling based on one's-
religious affiliation once
percent relapse affiliations
that passed in two thousand
sixteen and also your for that
so thank you so much- we also.
Ask another bill in two
thousand eighteen which. Would
provide training for teachers
on how to deal with these
issues. Again you know while
it's true we cannot legislate
compassion we cannot legislate
tolerance or whatnot. At the
same time it is important to
have are like to the officials.
Pass these type of- you know
bills or ordinances or what not
and I think that this
resolution the compassion
resolution. Is I definitely I a
big step in the right direction
to ensure that we as California
state that we want to have a
compassionate state. And we
need to work together in order
to do this and so- you know I.
Hope to work with you and I
hope to work with them that the
members of our community in
order to create a more
compassionate community because
we can't do this alone we- do
this together and we are
stronger together- so what what
lastly I wanted to say that- as
I mentioned the reports that we
had- recently put out. I'm
gonna it we've already looked
at a few on the table over
there so please. Feel free to
pick it up- and if there run
out then you can also find it
on our website and that's- at
C. A. dot care dot com you
should be able to find that
think in please- feel free to
reach out to me at the end.
Thank you thank you very much.
My name is James stay in line
with these so to look up by in
a the C. P. we- know our deal
this'll right organization in
the country. And is most we
don't know we are always been-
have always been about
inclusion that's all we were
founded by you know a diverse
group. Yeah in our founders
were white black some Jewish
and Christian. So funny for
everybody's right is our
mandate. I'm we strongly
support this bill because you
know even though other parts of
the country criticized for
compassion we feel that our
compassion is our strength. We
have to do things together in
order to survive and move ahead.
We watch in horror as his hate
crimes against the people of
different faiths of now a
different sexual orientations
of different races have
increase. And we had teachers
who harassed in this county. We
have I've had student move away
because the parents could not
stand the harassing to get
because their muscle. I'm
trying to be vehicles A. I. as
a teacher you know we sometimes
get carried away. Yeah we are
yeah I've worked with lots of
these people here a lot of
familiar faces here you know.
Assume the caller is from in
two. This Fisher. For the big
day. On issues like this yeah
yeah all these great crimes a
risen based on the Brewster
rhetoric coming out of
Washington from our so called
leaders. No so the people who.
Feel justified people who go on
yeah. Will used to hide behind
the Bible for ya to justify to
hatred and bigotry you know
forget about the teaching the
Bible about the treatment
strangers in the good
Samaritan- saying Jesus will
children on Sunday should but
the border on Monday. Hello we
feel that this resolution and
other steps. A go a long way to
healing the soul of our state
and a and a country. We're
given our strong support to it
thank you thank you very much.
And that's how I would- of new
haven who will member the
president Sir object to come up.
And what's your children while
great. I'm sure they have all
come with some comments to make.
Good evening everybody this to
my grandson and you sing and is
the reason for me to work with
the schools and education in
general and he's a kid so could
you would sing and he when we
were coming here I asked him on
that. When he asked we really
going I said that is interfere
I log so he asked me if there
is any Melissa committee
members or you know. Who will
be the at high said I don't
know this is my first time so
but I know there will be some
good dialogue about the
bullying in the schools he said
that's good you know then. I
don't have to worry about that.
This is ten year old. So in
respect of the time I will not.
Keep my a common set of just
testimony that this is the what
we are doing for other future
followed kids of and one thing
I would ask from you being
assembly members that more
funding for the field funding
for that for the schools. And
the there is a restorative
justice justice practices so
dole's- the they had to be a
funded fully so that we can
train our teachers and other
schools they're going to be and
thank you so much for choosing
this venue for the schools and
I'm not forget to commend you
and- stuff who invited me. To
come to this for thank you so
much thank you very much and
thank you very much for your
patience as well- next all like
to call all rock then rex fans
to bring a friend of mine I am
very a strong advocate for the
LGBTQ. Community rock fan.
Thank you for this moment to
address you. My name is rocks
and I'm advocate for
transgender women- I just want
to go I recognize that we face
a 100% unemployment there's not
one of its employed in the
legislature. And in our own
legislature in Sacramento at
any level. And I say that 80%
of we have an 80% murder rate
now I know why to define murder
different because you all know
about trans women getting
beaten knife to killed in the
street. But the factor my
community is so afraid to go
outside that when they do
they're covered up and they do
the best not to present as a
trans woman. So what do they do
they stay in that room. And I
don't care how strong you are
you can't stay in your room for
ever. When you become afraid to
walk out your front door. At
some point you kill yourself
and I think that's just society
killing us the slow way. That's
how we get to the 80% The death
threats. It's happened to me
twice in the last two years San
Jose P. D. won't even show up
to take a report. So and you
know A. B. six fifty just got
killed this year in
appropriations that was Evan
low's. Attempt to say that when
were murdered. Were at least
worth a check mark in law
enforcement killed that bill
so- that is the hurdle that you
have to go through I own a
house up in. By writing. I'm
actually afraid to go up there
and I'm selling my house
because it's just not safe for
me to go up there anymore. Info
if finally I want to stress
that this is not just because
people think we dress funny and
of our appearance this is been
institutionalized hate. In the
eight in fifty four cities in
this state passed laws that
said wearing the dress of the
opposite sex. Is he went to
prison. You went to jail for
six months in if you can did it
the second time. You are a race
from society put an insane
asylum for the rest of your
life. So it's the imp the
students talked about implicit
bias and that's basically what
we face I would just add a
convention in Sacramento this
week. A professor from UCSF
which claims to know all about
us. Got up and gave a lecture
on empathy. But what was the
example he used. It was a man
wearing high heels. And he
thought it was funny I don't.
So I'll close in asking and
addressing the audience. I know
when I walk in here most of you
say. Have nothing in common
with trans. We what is life.
One car pulls up behind this
week's we steering wheel a
little tighter. When we will
know what it's like to judge
just by our appearance. We what
it's like to lose jobs not get
jobs just because of our repair.
And I think that goes for me
communities and we would like
to join you in changing. The
acceptance of hate against all
of this because of our parents.
Thank you very much. How old
were were past eight o'clock
through I really like to in
respect of everybody's time- I
just wanted to maybe invite to
more than any of further
comment please feel free to
contact my office or arches
office or anybody. Office here
so I'm just picking to randomly
and I have a. Alison McDonnell
Alison Huron. Good evening
assembly member Kansen Chu
assembly member ash Kalra. Vice
mayor Koch saw one and- school
board president Chris nor would
I am so glad that you chose to
have this event here in
Milpitas- I am president of
sunny hills neighborhood
association and a member of the
mission peak Unitarian
universalist congregation and
Fremont. I did not have the
pleasure of attending the. The
discussions that you had in
Fremont about the- possibility
of. Creating a homeless
navigation center. Fremont is a
compassionate city according to
the ordinance that you pastor
proclamation that you passed in
Fremont and yet people I've
heard through friends who were
in attendance at that meeting
at those meetings or saying
terrible things about homeless
people who for the most part
are homeless because they can't
afford the housing prices here.
Because they can't afford the
rapidly increasing runs because
they may have a fixed income or
disability or- a mental problem.
And so my question and I think
that the students actually went
to some way towards some
proposals that might do what
I'm talking about. My question
for you was. How how do we go
beyond a declaration a
proclamation and make it real
in the community to create a
change in the culture which is
very order for there to truly
be compassion and communities.
Thank you thank you very much
hello. Kellogg I've been
getting some ideas from the all
on the analyst and- Diane say
the diss would really serve as
a reminder I am definitely
aware that we have a lot of
work ahead of us in I would
rely on your comments and your
suggestions. Your
recommendation as we go forward.
By the way Alison I have not
received your invitation to do
you of the hollow in part here.
Your your your problem. You
promised me a have not receive
it but then. Next one of the
like to invite peak here Bob
yeah she PJ. The drummer. The
tight hole frontier. Hello all
thank you so much for our
convening here and this is
something that I advocating for
years myself but I just wanted
to bring to of. My name is PJ
hereby actually. And I'm a
founder activator of. East
Akron act I'm for tylko
Japanese. Partnerships and the
sea and creative power meant. I
am also a founding member and
charter member of San Jose
tackle forty six years in the
making. Anyway I I'd like to
just bring to your attention as
an artist. There is a strong
and growing group. As that's
creating a movement called
coalition of artists and
creative for passionate
communities. And it's through.
We've in spirituality activism
art. We feel that the arts is
essential tool. Compassionate
community building and its
partnerships who share
principles of empathy and
empowerment by voice and
visibility through creative
expression. Please note arc our
communities are real Eddie for
this movement. And it has to
happen here in California
regarded as radical but let's
show. That we are actually a
model- for progressive
compassionate change. Thank you
PJ no I haven't survey after
the committee chair of the
state assembly our
entertainment sports tourism
media tech OG. I am very happy
por last your idea of advocates
for ten million dollar more
true California arts council
who there some money there you
know but a part of the money
would actually of dedicated for
to California prison all make
sure that this- people that
incarcerated has an
opportunity. To express
themselves through art and use
our the as the as part of their
healing so was stellar I would
like to open up the microphone
of the- on the días an ashram
will go first yeah I'll all in
the end so much of the almost
peak fast which I you know all
you know I can do- and- I want
to thank all the panelists I
mean really. Like I said is an
all star group of folks are so
committed to the community and
really exemplifies what we need
to spread. More I think we're
very blessed to represent the
community that we deal we
certainly have a lot of
problems but we have a lot of
compassion as well it does make
it a bit of a mention. Of but
what I am trying to with the
legislating compassion I do
think a very proud to be a co
author almost always think that
you need to state your
intention because your
intentions in your thoughts
leader actions. Well I
absolutely. Masters like the
but this Hindu and us kind of
manifesting itself to
legislation in some sense but I
think that each and everyone of
you in some matter. Reflected
that right that is the of the
way you think of when you treat
others. The way the US your
spiritual your thoughts- always
come for your actions anyway.
This expanded health care to.
Undocumented the residents
letter twenty six that is
legislating compassion. Right
and that's a very real action.
Of that goes beyond the words
there's plenty of things that
we can do as a what I would.
Ask in but kind of in my-
comments- is. Bob as father job
deferring to an and a couple
others well- me obstruction to
locked up in cages we have
children being away from their
parents. I that we need to show
our actions are cash to actions
of standing up is families. We
are homelessness as was
mentioned actuation Fremont
I've heard the same thing as
house elves a Cupertino Paul
to. You know everyone has
compassion but then when
there's a when it comes to
doing something about it in
your own backyard people show
up and many of those people are
in your congregations. On the
weekends or during the course
of the week. And so we need to
do what a better job myself
absolutely first online
included- job really articulate
that. Not just about how we
pray or who we pray to- but how
do we actually act upon that
believe that faith and that
means standing up for our how.
How's community as vigorously
as compassionately as possible-
are incarcerated and informally
incarcerated those getting
released people get worried
sometimes also be released well
the best way to make sure. Of
that- that there's no harm
because is to embrace them and
bring them back into the
community and to love them. And
I think that. That is what I.
Lots legislating compassion and
is also demonstrating
compassion through our actions
and I think also you. It's a
very tough last comment on
makes a very tough place- to
live very expensive a lot of
people working really hard are
struggling to survive. Some are
are homeless or very close to
it- somewhere but clear our
bathroom summer serving our
food- and- there are a lot of
people struggling back right
now and I see some of the
teachers reading- wearing red
is about to teachers striking
and- school workers striking
in. Chicago and I just wanna
make mention of the workers in
the plot the workers again I
think that we must do you can
up left everyone. Especially
those are struggling to make
ends meet and ends up. As we
beat. Up were as the feet of
the homeless and on housing
that's and ways to by the way
to put them as well. As as well
as that physical nourishment
the spiritual nourishment and
that activism that of that- all
of our face the can down.
Straight through action and so
on this very hopeful being
here- in and not just hearing
to live for the folks the
audience but- our panelists and
so I think that. Plenty of
cause of action. That that we
can take up. And I know that
there's nothing we can't
achieve of fighting all that.
The hatred and bullying and
bigotry fighting it with the
love that I see a is
unstoppable and so I want to
thank all of you. Right thank
you all. And large. Thank you
symbol member for a hosting
this important discussion and
also they can assembly member
Kalra for signing on this-
resolution. A special thanks
all the panelists everybody who
came out today. It was
interesting that almost all of
used almost very similar if you
look at the key principles. And
again goes back to the golden
rule you know treat others the
way you want to be treated. And
so I felt that- you know what
you like this is a greater than
what divide this and we are the
human race and- we have so much
to- in common- the speaker
mention about compassionate
Fremont. I was a great charter
and everybody bought it to it
until it can be implementing
it. And to live out the can.
Values when we had the home
navigate to center. We had a
lot of ugliness that came out.
And I made a quote that you
know everybody wants to help
the homeless but just on doing
your me. And so we have to live
those principles and so in
Fremont we did end up-
unanimously. Voting for that.
Hello yes thank you. Although I
like to say we use one what
political lives on that. And so
now it's up to us to prove that
this will six will concept and
to make sure that we are the
trust of the community. And
hopefully with time the
committee will come to see it-
we had fights like this
previously I when it came to
four wheel housing it was the
same thing people audit fought
it. And then now the champion
it so I think the same will
happen with these. Centers so
I'm hopeful that we can all
come together- it you know for
the greater good. And that
support this effort that up
symbol members leading I think
this is the right thing and I
think California is compassion
state and we need to make sure
to let everybody know that.
Thank you. All right. Your to
five final word down trying to
see if the community of
Milpitas could speak if we
could get a little support if
you have access to the internet.
On the laptop. Superintendent
is helping her bill. You have a
slide show the little too many
the element of the deal all
right. Some abusing for just to
briefly- fill the time Milpitas
unified school district has
approximately ten thousand.
Three hundred students were K.
twelve school district we have
one school ten elementary
schools two middle schools an
adult- high school adult-
learning center and we also
provide our academic services
to Elmwood- in the community of
Milpitas unified school
district's looks very much like
this room. And if you ever get
a chance to visit- our website
right on the front are moniker
is culture of we- and the
culture we that describe to. Is
chest of has just resonated
with a number of things that
I've heard in this room we take
the approach that we have a
number of different religions.
Different we have a number of
different- ethnicities
diversity languages and that in
order for us to be able to get
along. Not only the get along
with to thrive even in a
capitalistic. ID that have the
bill this compassionate- within
our students as they go through
their educational journey
because there are a lot of
things that they're receiving.
I think that they're dealing
with and social media so we've
ascribed to in the previous
unified school district we call
of the culture we and I'm
hopeful- that we can show that
brief two minute video that we-
we shared. With our teachers.
Arm looks like it's going to
happen. Yeah yeah yeah. I
define the culture that misty
thousand clicks in the sense
that you can pull people with
different hobbies and. Together
with the many different events
that they provide many
different opportunities for
your a great job of making sure
that we higher highly qualified
staff that have that sense of
inclusivity. Hi my are about
the staff here in the US the is
how approachable everybody is
and how kind they are in the
fact that we're all student
center all of us want the best
for the. Students we are
passionate about kids. The list
is a melting pot of different
nationalities social economic
backgrounds. Yes skills and
talents. Our work with other
leadership students to create
activities on campus are
catering to all different
groups on campus because we are
very diverse student body so we
try to make sure that we have.
Certain activities each year
that entail to each of the
different
. Yeah the wi fi. Rain
and all the- home. You will
students together we build a
lifetime of healthy habits.
Together we make lasting
friendships that begin at
school. Together we are the
best of the best that's what
our students we facilitate
communication with staff
students and community members
together weeknight passion show
kindness encourage problem
solving and critical thinking
in our students together we
participate in after school
activities to contribute to the
community at large together we
express ourselves by telling
important stories together. We
provide pathways for learners
to become their past. Together
we use data that comes from
assessment to help students
improve. And. Together we give
all to second chance and
learning together we celebrate
the cheapness of students from
all backgrounds together we
empower our students to create
a better future. This is the
best year ever. Hashtag Loki is
strong also if you is the thing.
Thank you rumored letter do an
overall over a paltry any
additional comment so. I would
I would wreck would just share
with you that there is power in
the U. with which you would
like to see. That is on tap.
That you have the opportunity
you allies utilized as you look
at how we turn this from
legislation. To action and I
recommend that you reach out to
the community because that's
what they're looking for. And
that's what they want to be a
powerful thank you we
appreciate you hosting this
event here today. We thank you
very much for a lot of- using
your facility but before we the
Jordan I like to- introduced my
staff to all of you the
personal name and faces
together. And stepping up this
my- the chief of staff and from
sacramental any any fan- way
how okay learn from them come
to the from. Caitlyn and
working under there's a Linda
those three are my legislative
staff from of Sacramento and
districts out. Of a Matthew.
And Simone- world on rock on a
log my- district director.
Anybody else here. All we are
in and I. Car us the district
director Stacy Stacy she okay
with us though- I apologize
that I will not be able to-
call all all all of you do you
as a speaker here. But again
feel free to contact my office
well in the bill ideas or any
suggestions and comments. And
again thank you very much for
your patient and thank you very
much. For a state was till the
end thank you goodnight